el cielo de crimea amaneció Con este
humo espeso
producto del ataque con aviones no
tripulados a un depósito de combustible
en el puerto de sebastopol base de la
flota rusa en el mar Negro la ofensiva
fue atribuida a Ucrania por las tropas
prorrusas de la Península
en la madrugada se produjo un ataque de
vehículos aéreos no tripulados
desafortunadamente fue efectivo el
trabajo de extinción de incendios fue
organizado de inmediato ahora la unidad
de mando está funcionando el fuego se ha
contenido de manera efectiva 10 tanques
cisternas quedaron destruidos en una
superficie de casi 1000 metros cuadrados
100 reportes de personas heridas ni
afectaciones en infraestructuras civiles
las autoridades aseguraron que el
incidente no representa un peligro para
el suministro de combustible en la
Península que fue anexionada por Rusia
en 2014 pero que es reconocida
internacionalmente como territorio de
Ucrania
Durante los últimos meses se han
reportado numerosos ataques ucranianos
contra la Península en su mayoría con
aeronaves no tripuladas el presidente
voló de mirza lensky ha dicho que la
retoma de la Península es uno de sus
objetivos primordiales entre tanto los
habitantes de la zona han expresado su
preocupación
cuando los drones atacan te despiertan
por supuesto no hay ningún lugar donde
puedas dormir tranquilo la casa tiembla
te preocupas por tus hijos pero
confiamos en que el sistema antimisiles
funciona bien y que se va a su Paul está
bien protegido nos hemos acostumbrado
ejercicios militares constantes y ya
casi no los notamos las autoridades de
crimea ordenaron la construcción de una
línea defensiva fortificada entre la
Península y el resto de Ucrania mientras
las fuerzas ucranianas aseguran que es
inminente una contraofensiva para las
próximas semanas